all right well thank you very much
welcome to the second half of Lydia's
tutorial and uh well may as well get
started Lydia okay welcome back so just
to recap what we've done in the first
part of the first part which I thought
would be just the first part we talked
about information and work you know
these two concepts are related and then
in the second part of the first part we
started talking about treating some more
dynamics as a resource theory and I
introduced his framework of thermo
operations where we allow for unit areas
that conserve energy in entropy and we
allow for thermal States as modeled by
give States to be connected to my system
okay and then we talked a little bit
about why is the assumption of thermal
States is partially justified and he saw
that there's still some open questions
and there's still some up with questions
about why we allow for unit areas at all
okay so we have this model which is a
very simple kind of toy model and we're
gonna see what we can do with it so
first let's look at a simple example
which is when the hamiltonian is a
generate so then what you get you
allowed all the all the unitary
operations and you're like we're allowed
give States but give States on a
degenerate hamiltonian just mean a fully
mixed age so this is the framework of
noisy operations you loud mixin sillas
and you allowed unitary operations so if
you have this the order that you get in
your states in in your resources is
majoras asian okay and so first just the
formula here and then we'll see how to
visualize it so this just means that if
you order the eigenvalues of the stage
then starting from from the biggest
eigenvalue once said this sum on one
side is always bigger than the sum
on the other side so this is for all
okay so what this means here essentially
that row is more pure than Sigma and we
look into this in a in a moment there's
a very nice review of this framework by
current Nicole Rob's Perkins and some
other people so what you get if you have
this kind of this kind of pre-order on
your set of resources then your
monotones are all the should convex
functions so in particular you have this
thing here which is the divergence or
the Renny divergence to the set of free
states so this is so some of you are
very familiar with this and I will not
say anything new for the others this is
almost like like an isometric kind of
distance measure it's not a distance
because it's asymmetric but acts like
this so it's a monitor that is
operations and the The Closer that the
more similar that row is to the state on
the right than the small the smaller
this is or the big okay and the
classical formulation is like this and
then there are several quantum
generalizations they all have different
properties they are useful for different
things and as we will see well in this
case it doesn't matter because since all
unit areas are allowed you can always
diagonal as every state so therefore you
like essentially back in the classical
case okay and later on it will matter
but will not go in much detail about
this so you can use these guys to define
an entropies and therefore all the
entropies are are also monotone under
this which makes sense so how do you
visualize this preorder one very popular
tool is to build the so-called Lorenz
curves so let's see what this means
so first you have your your state and
you know how normally you can represent
probability distributions like this kind
of bar graph okay where he is like the
probability
the first outcome and of the second and
third for example for they say that is
green and this state would be maximally
mixed state yes this be the next okay so
you just sort your eigenvalues and then
you build a step sign function from this
which looks like this so here we have
three different sets and then you
integrate these steps function yeah and
you get the Lorenz curve so straight
lines corresponds to the to the
maximally mixed state and all the others
are kind of above the straight line and
now how do you how do you visualize your
pre-order here so it's very simple if
one if one curve is completely above the
other then it can be transformed then it
can do this transformation right so for
example you can choose from the green
state into this into this maximally
mixed age yes into the orange stage
because it's completely above each other
so this this condition corresponds to
this condition here but for example it
cannot transform this green into the
bull nor can you transform the blue into
the green any simple game yes okay
and then you can say okay so this is in
the simple example you get into pieces
as monotones you get this very nice
pre-order let's see what happens if if
now you allow for full hamiltonians and
actually in this case I don't want to
say that little is known but there still
a lot to to explore so for example we
have a pre-order for block diagonal
studs so these are states that are block
diagonal in the energy eigenbasis so we
could almost call them classical stage
yes so you don't have coherences between
different different levels different
energy levels and in this case it - it
would be the priority to get its thermal
modulation which is kind of a rescale
metallization we'll go into this in a
bit the mono turns again not
surprisingly the relative entropy to the
thermal stage is a monotone so in
general there's a nice result by Guren
and Brando you know if you have some
kind of a measure that behaves more or
less like a distance and you you
computed towards the the Gibbs
towards the free stage then this will
always be a monotone in your resource
theory under some assumptions yes and
then you're gonna get this risk a Lorenz
curves and if you want to nice reviews
on them there's this paper by Joe Ennis
and also by orders can open him so how
do you build now this this Lorenz curve
so the idea is that before the only
thing that matter was the probabilities
they needed to be ordered so more pure
states are better but now you kind of
have to wait this with the energies so
the way to do it is you first need to
risk a audio eigenvalues multiply them
by the kind of the energy of your stage
yes like this and sort them again from
bigger to smaller then you build your
step function again where this this
things here just means that you you kind
of stretch this x axis such that in the
end the function has this kind of
boundaries of like being it would be
like from one here
and all the way up one here okay it's
just so that it's easier to compare
systems of different sizes for example
states of different systems yes sir you
built this
you risk killed them you build a step
function you integrate you get to
Lawrence curve which is just like the
other one yes and then you have again a
nice visual visualization and I think I
don't know if Turnitin will talk about
this in a store called Carlo go into
more detail but if you read any papers
about thermal operations you'll see this
this Lorenz curves all the time okay and
then again the pre order is the same so
it just tells you that if one curve is
always above the other then you can do
the transformation so yes so I'll talk
about what is the sufficient condition
was the necessary condition so one thing
that you get from here so this pre order
as I said is only it's only completely
the final on on block diagonal stage
okay
so then but what you get from this is
that you get that the free orange is
free and Isaiah monotones for all states
including coherent States yes and what
are these free energies so essentially
there are a risk held divergence so you
take this thing that you knew was a
monotone and then you multiplied by Katy
okay and then you take away this look
that which is a constant that depends on
landed on your Hamiltonian so why why I
mean we had such a nice monotone why are
we transforming into into into this it
seems like there's no added value and
the added value is just to relate this
to the normal thermodynamics okay so for
classic states this is also a necessary
condition so in particular if you if you
go for that use here is one then what
you get is a trace of the it's kind of
the average energy of your stage my name
is Katie the entropy of the state and
this is the pre energy in traditional
thermodynamics so what we've done here
so what we've done here was to simply
you know to start with this very almost
naive model of just saying well we'll
only allow for unit areas let's preserve
energy and then we allow for the gift
sites to come for free and then see that
we are we already recovering a
thermodynamic low and quantities that we
add in thermodynamics plus now that we
have a quantum state in there's lots of
states out of equilibrium we get a whole
family of them ok as you can change this
parameter alpha here
and you get a whole family of of
monotones that for classical States are
also from sufficient conditions
necessary condition system and these are
scaling in particular what it does is
that if you evaluate this on a pure
state of a certain energy then it gives
you just this energy okay so what the
free energy tries to encode is kind of
the work value of your stage because it
means that you could you could transform
it to like a weight that you live -
exactly - II okay so this is kind of the
mode hopefully very convincing
application of this framework telling
you that well we do get something useful
out of it so there's also many
realizations of the third law that you
can get from here by using other
monotones which tell so what the third
law tells us that you cannot call
something to the ground state if you
only have finite resources you need an
infinite time or an infinite path or
variations over this ok so there's
different results that recover this we
already sold and ours principle being
like the world cost operating a system
in the presence of a memory and we saw
this this result is kind of for the
average case if you have many copies but
there's also single-shot results that
use the way you can have like a
probability of error that things can go
wrong with some small probability they
have some tolerance and then the entropy
that come up obviously are not then the
I'm an entropy but some other
single-shot entropy okay so this is very
nice voice to give a physical
interpretation to your to your
information theoretical entropies and
clearly if you have some finite size
effects like your bath is finite then
this limits the efficiency of your of
your procedure this because if you
remember the protocol to do this erasure
it assumed that she had access to like a
heat bath that was as big as I wanted
why could draw whatever qubits I wanted
and now if you want to study more
realistic situations where this is not
the case then you get all this finite
size effects okay now something that I
will not talk about much because
Jonathan will go into more detail later
in the week for tuition theorems which
what they tell you is well these results
are kind of average results so what is
the probability of things go wrong or
how badly can things go wrong and what
they tell is that this probability is
exponentially suppressed on on the kind
of variation that you'd get and this is
say it sounds like how would you even
quantify this violation of the of the
interview so of the expected energy that
you can extract from a process or not so
one thing that you could do is this well
measure my measure my energy reservoir
in the beginning measuring at the end
and then use this as the work extracted
but of course that if you have a
coherent process then you end up also
with a coherent state in your in your
reservoir and then you have to be much
more careful about how you model of this
so like in the same way that he had to
be more careful on in the quantum memory
you could not just reduce now here in
this case you also have to treat these
things it's more care okay
so the other thing that you can do is
well we have this framework where we
have only one conserved quantity which
is the energy okay we only care about
the energy and now say well maybe in
real life there's also other laws like
momentum conservation or some you know
some other quantity that needs to be
preserved and then let's see well let's
just expand the framework and what we
say now okay so now we have these other
observables and our unitary also needs
to commute with them so it cannot add
any momentum or candidate if these are
things so what we get from here well we
get essentially all most of the same
results but now for a different for a
different kind of gibbsite generalized
give state okay we're just happy you
have kind of a different effective
temperature for each of this for each of
these observables and again all this
typicality thermalization
results apply so in particularly static
thermalization results so if you take a
maximal mixed state on the big system
then locally it appears to be like this
yes
also the passivity results also hold
here and the monotones you get not
surprisingly you get again this fake
distance this divergence to thee to
generalize give state and we're starting
to see the first protocols to try to
convert between these two between all of
these quantities so for example you
could have one reservoir that from the
stores energy in one reservoir that only
stores spin but as a degenerate
Hamiltonian and you want to and you want
to trade between these two quantities
okay and here they're very interesting
effects when this quantity is do not
commit in this is a nice area to explore
okay
but so far most of them most of this
could have been could have been almost a
classical framework so when we start to
see like real quantum examples or
quantum phenomena
we can start by looking at coherence so
the first thing is that we could be
interested in implementing you know
rotations in your stage like well okay
like we saw before like going from zero
to plus etc that there's our coherence
but in general you all is how do you
implement a unitary on in LabVIEW you
shoot a laser at some system okay and
this laser is a very big coherent system
and you can say well actually I want to
account for this for this resource that
I'm using and can i optimize this
resource so one of the first results on
this topic was quite surprising which
was that this coherence is in a way
catalytic so what does this mean well so
suppose that I I model my my source of
coherence as say harmonic oscillator but
if it's a laser then it's a very large
coherent state on this harmonic
oscillator so what are the properties of
this that are important in order to
implement unitary okay so the properties
turned out to be just two aspects of
this
so one this M is easy to understand it's
like the lowest occupied energy level of
my say harmonic oscillator and the other
one measures how well spread this
coherence is it's this term here and
what I mean by what I mean by these are
the relevant properties it means that if
I want to implement some unitary to some
precision epsilon in some system than
the only things that matter are these
okay so then you can see well I want to
implement a unitary and then what
happens to my coherence reservoir and
this is the idea so there's some back
action of course of implementing it an
operation yes
so my reservoir is changed and in
particular the state gets kind of more
stretched
but it does not degrade this relevant
parameter here this this Delta because
it stretches of course it lowers this M
which in the end it just means that you
know the M is not really important it
just means that at some point if you
keep stretching it you're going to hit
the bottom yes and once you once you hit
the bottom then at some point it starts
affecting your your total coherence so
what can you do well I can just pump
this up with energy yes I just add
energy to this system
so this is interesting because it sounds
like you can trade quick if you start
with some initial coherence then you can
just add energy and keep this coherence
for all practical purposes that you're
interested in
yes so in that sense it's what we say
that it acts as a as a catalyst anyway
this is in the very specific case of
this of taking our money causality is
actually involved in both directions
then you can start looking at more
realistic reservoirs and and so for
example there's this paper by Imperial
in which they give you an explicit
protocol to extract to extract work from
Korean states to implement any tries in
coherent States and then later to
restore the reservoir this okay there's
also quite some work now on from two
years ago on resource series of
coherence that just try to decide the
system and then resource series that
tried to study coherence together with
together with thermodynamics so this is
also an interesting direction to explore
now finally to go back to the question I
was asked before the break
I mean the the elephant in the framework
is that we allow it for all this unit
tears to be applied but of course that
if you apply unitary this means that you
you choose a Hamiltonian you turn it on
at some point and then you turn it off
right in order to do this or your our
Hamiltonian could even be something that
is time dependent okay in order to do
this you actually you need to have like
an explicit clock system okay that keeps
track of everything so for example in
ion traps they sometimes use extra ions
that act as clocks themselves
okay so then we really want to have like
if if thermodynamics is about to count
and counting then we want to account
also for this for these resources so we
need to expand our framework to think
about giving agents less control just
say well you can turn on some
interaction then you can turn it off
later but with not very good time
precision so that you you're forced to
model this explicitly so what are first
steps so there's this idea of having an
ideal clock that is just a particle in a
line perfectly coherent and in this case
well its catalytic you can use it as
many time as you want and it's also
allows you to implement your any test
perfectly there's some results now in
which you modify your framework such
that you don't allow for unit tests but
you only allow for thermal contact
thermalization
and and now more recent thing there will
be a paper about this by misha i think
there's some explicit models for some
clocks which are finite sized systems
and then they study like how how big how
good this implementation is depending on
the dimension of the clock and how much
the clock is degraded but again this is
a very interesting area for for research
for directions okay and
you know yes nope up there isn't in a
sense that quarks are coherence clocks
near this goodness
as far as you know yes yes you know they
both use coherence maybe for one of them
you want you know you wanted for a
specific application then you you build
them differently but yes I mean you
could call them the same yes yeah
I'd say yes the state is degraded but
the parameters of interest do not
sure it I mean these results assume that
now you apply this code to a different
system so in this sense then it would
not be if you keep applying to the same
system yes otherwise no no it's good
it's good
it stretches the tongue so okay so the
idea is if used the clock on a system
and then you can I use it on a different
system that's okay okay then these
parameters are not change of course if
you want to use the same fork in the
same system then this is a problem yes
because then the errors are correlated
yes in this I think correct me if I'm
wrong but I don't think it has been much
explored okay so there's one thing that
I haven't told before I go to open
questions in this whole talk and I
didn't know very well where to put it to
fit a story which are heat engines and
small heat engines okay so I decided to
put them here because heat engines are
an example of autonomous thermal
machines or thermal protocols where
precisely you you just turn on some
interaction and you forget about it you
don't need any explicit control later
alone so the idea which is the idea
behind thermal engines is to export two
resources that have a common so in this
case to heat lots of different
temperature okay so it's like you can
take one to be your environment and take
the other one to be an extra resource
that you have but you just make it very
big and then you want to use this to do
something so in this case it could be
you want to use it to cool some
additional system that is also in a gift
state or it could use it you could want
to use it to extract work yes so like
take care to be a harmonic oscillator
and you want it to pump this up so and
the question was
well how big this is engineered to be
can we do it with only just say imagine
having only here three cubits do you
still get very efficient engines or not
and the result is that yes you can get
Carnot efficiency but let's let's be a
bit careful about what this means
so the idea between this and a be behind
this engines is you take one qubit and
you put each qubit and come in contact
with a bath okay so that it thermal eyes
is it but you choose these gaps very
carefully such that they match in some
way that is convenient for an engine so
in this case like this gap Plus this gap
equals that gap so then you can turn on
some interaction and in fact in this
case there are some results that say
most most interactions will do which is
just which is you know energy conserving
so for example in this case it could
mean that if I get this right could mean
that when this one goes down exactly and
this one goes down and this one goes up
or you can you can change yes exactly
right because I don't know yes and vice
versa if this one goes up and this one
goes up then that one goes down yes and
then you do this in a way because you
know that here you always get this sight
is always getting thermalized so you
always get a gives distribution here
always give gives distribution here and
you fine-tune these probabilities like
by fine-tuning the gap you fine-tune the
the probability that you get such that
in the end the result on this state that
is not getting thermalize all this all
the time for example could be that well
I'm always cooling down this the system
here or the opposite I'm always pumping
the system up yeah and you can do this
by just letting it run and it reaches
current efficiency which is the maximum
efficiency in the in
in the classical like macroscopic is now
what is the catch well you need to
fine-tune these gaps very carefully you
need to make sure that they actually
thermalize so there is some gap some
cubit in your path that has the same gap
here so that these things actually
thermalized yes so in the end you kind
of still have this some assumptions that
you have infinitely large thoughts
yes but they're just a bit more in a
different layer okay good so this is
actually something that would be very
cool for applications because if you
have such a thing then you could put it
inside a quantum computer for example
and have this computer self cooing all
the time
okay so now
for Maurice by the way for more results
on this several papers by a post cryptic
and there's also a few reviews that I'll
talk about at the end yes okay so now
let's talk about open questions so first
my favorite area would be this clocks in
control I think it's where there's more
room for exploration now and also it
gets you know
more useful interesting results so one
idea one thing that we need to work out
is what are the most efficient clocks
like what is even like the best protocol
for this both from the point of view of
theory but also from looking at specific
experiment setups so the second thing
that we can do and it's been done is to
combine all this all this thermal
operations framework with insights from
reference frame frameworks restaurant
frame resort series okay because your
cork is like a reference then apply
further restrictions like for example
you know it could be that you cannot
have this fine tuning of parts of
Hamiltonians in some experiment so what
you have to do is go to an
experimentalist and ask them is this a
reasonable assumption to have and then
try to build a framework for this then
there's not yet a clean framework to
treat this question of clocks there's
not at least I haven't seen like a cream
kind of resource through formulation of
how much control you give to an agent
how you quantify this there to be
something small and simple to do again
seeing how much we need coherence how
much coherence is involved in this and
finally you know since we're talking
about Cox then you can relate this to
more foundational problems like the
problem of time in quantum theory
okay so the other thing is try to make
this whole thing more realistic so try
to make it less of a that's very Coco
more more like a real car free in the
film so one idea is to have more
operational notions of temperatures so
instead of modeling the bath why this
gibbsite is kind of a statistical
approach which we know already that it's
not true it's not a gift set
it's like typically close to a give
state but it's not a gift set yep so we
can either try to model this kind of
knowledge of with high probability it's
close to give state or or we can go from
more operational approach so for example
the way temperature is defined by karna
and there's a very nice overview of this
in five months
lecture notes it's just saying okay I
don't know what temperature is but I
know there's some things called this
heat bath and I know there's one
parameter that matters for the purpose
of work extraction okay
so then by then seeing kind of then
saying okay then let's suppose that I
have something called reversible engines
okay that I can run in one way and then
the other and the work out one way is
same as the work in the other way just
just this idea so I start from the the
work engine the heat engine which is
something I can actually measure right
how much what comes out how much work
comes in and then I see okay so now
let's try to compose this heat engines
like say you know I have a bath right
I'm just going to call it the reference
I'm just gonna say this parameter is
equals one call is the temperature and
see how much work I can extract from
here to another bath okay and have this
defined the temperature of this other
bath
so there's a whole argument that runs
like this and that later also results in
all the laws of thermodynamics but the
idea that I'm trying to express here is
that you don't start from this notion of
temperature you just start from
something operation like this work that
you can measure and from here you get
some parameter ization of your bath like
in this case the temperature so we could
try to
do the same for engines that we know
work in the quantum regime and then say
I'm plugging in a heat bath you know
maybe do this in an experiment I'd I
think it's at a certain temperature but
but let's see how much work I can get
out of this and let's see if I can
parameterize this by a single parameter
which probably is not gonna be the case
now there's been lots of work in finite
size effect there's been some work in
going beyond like this idea that the
boss is in a tensor product with with
with my system and going beyond the weak
coupling also to derive all these
thermalization typicality results okay
so this is something is active the other
thing is having some realistic
descriptions of resources for
experimentalist because maybe the
experimentalist doesn't know that his
system is in some some quantum said row
that described by density matrix but you
know they've done some tomography and
they know some confidence region around
this okay or then they know some some
other parameters some observable and I
want to know still you know how much
work can I extract from such it from
such a resource that I can only describe
in this way so in the way in the same
way that the original developers of
thermodynamics did okay I didn't have
you didn't know the exact state of your
system we just have some some things
called pressure and volume which is the
accessible information now we still have
this I mean in quantum information would
like to think that knows that we have
access to the to the density matrix but
in fact we still have some effective
description and yeah so the question is
then how what kind of effective
descriptions do experimentalist give us
and what can we do with them okay yes
and also you know in all this you know
this work we cared a lot about heat and
and bulk but it could be that you know
extra mentally as Talia look we have a
great way to cool our systems heat is
not a problem with access to infinite
energy work is not a problem actually
what we care about is coherence or what
you care about
no coherence times and these are the
relevant resources and we should be
building resource series that take these
things as the relevant things and try to
study them okay so the the the general
message of this section of opens of open
questions is go talk to experimentalists
and ask them what is important for them
and then you know build your models from
there not the other way around because
otherwise what we have is that we see
lots of experiments in quantum
thermodynamics and some of them seem a
bit contrived that oh we're measuring
work in this way and why in this way
because it fits your your theoretical
model yes but it's not like a work that
you could later use for something else
it's not a very operational or
meaningful in that way yes so we need to
flip this the other way around ok so the
other thing is that since we saw at
thermodynamics is so general it is just
a resource theory and we applied it to
microscopic systems and you apply to
quantum systems and we can try to apply
it to other kind of otologist so we can
take for example it has been some work
on this like when applying it to
generalized probability theories and
it's to very if you're very baby steps
what's been done here and we can try to
see like Oh what kind of GPT is gets a
thermodynamic get thermodynamic laws
that resemble our world or not and could
this be a parameter to try to to
restrict and to read arrive quantum
theory like it's done now with locality
and correlations so the other thing that
one can do is then if you have this if
you derive if you write an axiomatic
thermodynamic in different physical
theories then you can try to relate them
and try to see when they are similar
when they are not finally
there's a whole EDS CFT field which uses
thermodynamics but some of the notions
used to have a can be seen as a bit
naive for example the notions of
normalization used or the fact that
thermal sites are all represented by the
Gib stage so this kind of things we can
take some some kind of the operational
insight that you gain from this
framework and try to apply it to other
fields of research yes also like the
insight that information is subjective
and thermalization is subjective and you
always need to model your agent
explicitly could be useful
yeah okay with this I am reaching the
end so there's a few reasons there's a
few reviews of which here I'm only
repeating the three that I mentioned
during the talk but there's a few others
so this talks explicit just about
quantum information apply to different
areas of thermodynamics this one you
know here we have a it's a bit you know
a bit like me this talk is a very like
broad overview more to give you
intuitions and not so much going into
mathematical details so if you want a
mathematical detail of a specific part
then in this case in this paper they
flash out like noisy operations really
really well okay and you can see like
how these Lorentz curves come from and
how you get all these monotones etc etc
okay so if you do then later I would
like to start your own resource theory
thinking oh let's a disarray assumption
or let's take this one out then I would
definitely recommend reading this before
to see how one precedes once you have
this operational principles set and
finally I didn't say much about
thermalization results
and this is a very nice review of of the
field it's okay no this carry is a
wealth of thermodynamic presentations
and posters these are just the ones I
saw and there's probably more so I
encourage you to to go to all these
talks
so in particular Carlo will talk about
resource here where you can you have
these two resources of heat and work so
you don't give the keep set for free a
priori but you can't it also has an
explicit resource and you'll export this
so it would be a very nice follow-up to
this talk Jonathan will talk about many
things including fluctuation serums in
more detail than I've been then I talked
to you yes and there's also all these
posters that you should go to and that's
it thank you very much for it
so questions
so you're the this way of measuring
coherence it somehow involves a choice
of a phase right right so somehow this
operator that you bet you saw Delta plus
Delta adjoint it measures the real part
of the of the coherence does this matter
somehow so we got this measure because
it's a measure that matter is right with
we thought okay we have this Web this
purpose which is implementing a unitary
and then let's see what's the measure
that turns out to be relevant it turns
out to be the real place you're asking
me yes I know that the question is
different yes would I times Delta minus
delta dagger be as as good I don't know
but there are people in the room who do
looking at you know yes yes I mean
further questions the resource theory
that you define here it can also be
defined in a pure classical settings for
example you can imagine a probably
distribution over phasor space that is
and use couple your system to a
tourmalet state exactly in the same way
I was wondering if there is any
fundamental difference between this
quantum problem and classical problem
that is defined only on phases space and
I guess the second part of the question
is that what you call quantum quantum
thermodynamics or coherence the effect
of coherence in countermand dynamics
isn't it's very similar to just having
non equilibrium probably distributions
in classical setting let's say I can
have stationary distributions and non
stationary distributions so when you
when you think about non stationary
distributions there are some extra
constraint on the possible
transformation that you can make from
one state to another
that is just due to the time dependence
of this so for example if the initial
the first one is time independent the
second one the finances cannot be time
time dependent so is it really different
the type of constraint that you get in
quantum quantum too many times is it
different from what you're getting
classical's exactly classical setting
yeah you know this depends on what you
mean by different yeah I mean you kind
of saying I add one more constraint and
then I get one more resource that is
important in that sense it's very
similar I mean
I guess the quick
I guess the problem is that you want to
implement this quantum transition right
you want to treat this quantum problem
of like I want to I want to prepare this
state that is coherent so in that sense
it's an it's a new problem that you want
to treat but it solved with this okay
maybe lying but I think it's all with
the same kind of reference frame kind of
approach that the classical one would be
solved but yes just the fact that it now
allows you to to treat states that it
couldn't treat before right
this is the main think for me yes yes I
mean this is an it's only you know it's
only like a complete family of monotones
for classical state as well yes there
might be more generally quantum aspect
but we have not explored them so much
yet but the main thing is that now we
can treat all these quantum transitions
as well I would say I mean
look yes yes yes yes I know yeah I know
what you mean yes yes yeah in some other
things that for example these results on
thermalization and on typicality of
thermalization
are much easy to achieve because you
ever because you have a quantum space
which is a largest place so you get this
typicality much more easily which maybe
you could not justify your assumptions
as well if you had a completely
classical theory but are they really
quantum quantum things well we can you
know extract work from quantum
correlations you can't do this man
because he go through but any further
questions all right well if not actually
I've got one so lately I've been I've
stumbled upon a little bit of
controversy about the land our limit I
was wondering if you could comment about
of whether you've looked at any of these
critiques that have come out within the
last few years about it or whether you
just haven't looked at it do you want to
tell me any specific oh there's like
Norton and some other people came up
with some some critical critical claims
that the land our limit perhaps hadn't
improved in exactly the ways that they
would like to see it proved and I'm just
wondering if you if you've looked at
that cuz I haven't not in big detail so
what I've seen is like rebuttals of
things saying well I mean I when the
earth principle is a principle right you
know what you prove it you need to come
up with a framework and then you need to
say well these assumptions are
reasonable okay so now here we have a
framework that is you can question all
of these assumptions separately and then
see if there
within this framework it has been more
than proved you have finite size
Corrections you have no it's new people
bike for people any paper bike for
people from December say about what
happens if now if your heat bath is not
perfectly independent of of the system
you want tearaways and you get some
Corrections there at work as well at
cetera yes so now I mean if you're
talking about an objection of this type
then we'd have to discuss like what
assumptions they would like and yes if
someone knows but I'm happy to discuss
the assumption if there's if there's no
other questions let's again think Lydia
foreign for an excellent tutorial
[Applause]